hey 42 here if you've just watched a
matrix or you're a Californian who has
gone a little overboard on the weed
legalization celebrations you might be
wondering how do I know that I'm not
just part of a computer simulation does
SuperMario think it's pretty standard to
be attacked by suicidal Turtles all day
maybe Kimi from candy crush never
wondered why she isn't riddled with
diabetes it might seem obvious to us
that they are completely virtual but
who's to say that we aren't part of a
giant simulation maybe we're all NPCs in
a computer game so let's take the red
pill and the blue pill at the same time
because screw you Morpheus as we ask
ourselves is anything real thanks to
science fiction we often associate
simulated realities with computers but
doubting reality is far from a new thing
the Greek philosopher Plato who lived
around 2,500 years ago wrote about this
concept in his work the Republic he
pictured a cave with prisoners chained
to the wall and all I ever saw were the
shadows of others passing in front of a
fire projected up onto the wall in front
of them this is the only life the
prisoners had ever known and so they
would understandably believed that the
shadows were actual people it's similar
to the modern world where we look mainly
at people's virtual lives through social
media and we think of their actual lives
as far more exciting than our own when
in actual fact they are having the same
terrible time that we all are
the real problem comes up the definition
of AI cogito ergo sum I think therefore
I am
but that doesn't help us prove what you
are masterchief exists but he's just a
bunch of code that I can control John
Locke pointed out that we could never
actually know the real essence of
anything we could only deal with the
nominal essence meaning what we actually
experience of it rather than the whole
picture he said he was like looking at a
clock
face all you can see is the time that it
shows you don't have any idea what cogs
and wires are behind it making it work
so as much as we believe that we know
how the universe works behind the scenes
we're still really just clueless puppets
everything you experience comes in for
your various senses such as your sense
of smell sense of touch
etc but at the end of the day all of
these senses end up as electrical
impulses in your brain Daniel Kish had
his eyes removed at just 13 months old
due to retinal cancer and from a young
age he trained himself to echo locate
using clicks with his tongue and
listening for the echo he became so
proficient in this that he was able to
mountain bike and tell the difference
between different surfaces such as metal
and wood and when neurologists tested
him they found that his visual cortex
was being activated so that means that
he really was seeing objects using sound
not just hearing them the brain had just
swapped around some of the inputs your
body also senses an astonishing amount
of data more than you could ever
realistically process so if you wanted
to create a fake reality you wouldn't
even need to program in every tiny
detail since only a small fraction would
be experienced by the user at any one
time anyway right now there is air
pressure acting on every millimeter of
your body there's light bouncing off
objects from countless things outside of
the screen that you're staring at and
that strange pain in your elbow well I
don't know what that is and you should
probably get it checked out but that is
why we have pain it's like a red flag
that makes you pay attention to once a
specific area of your body because if
you listen to all the parts of your body
all the time your brain would simply be
overwhelmed with all the information so
then let's take this a step further if
perception is just electrical impulses
in your brain then your brain is also
just a lump of quite fancy meat full of
electrical impulses any idiot with some
bacon and the Taser can recreate that so
sure you're conscious
is more than just a material that makes
up your brain isn't it we call these
things substrate independent this means
something that is more than the stuff
that it is made up of waves are a good
example of this if you see a wave on the
ocean you think it's just water but it
has amplitude frequency and other
parameters like that and these
properties are not just a part of the
sea water they are part of the wave and
actually independent from the water so
the bacon and taser combination may
produce some similar matter to a brain
but it's not going to create the same
conscious thoughts like what is love and
what was that thing I supposed to be
doing right now
and why don't electrical eels
electrocute themselves so even if your
brain isn't meat if it's just a string
of code written by some scientist or
alien or a 2038 iPhone app that's not to
say that your consciousness isn't a real
thing all your ideas can still be unique
and original okay relatively original at
least if your brain is just a bunch of
code that doesn't mean that every force
you have has already been decided just
that the initial conditions have already
been set and this leads us to our own AI
as we build more and more advanced
programs
it makes the likelihood that we are
living in a simulation seem even higher
just think about it if we can code
simulated brains was to say that we
aren't already a part of one illa ma
squad said it's only about a one in a
billion chance that we are not in a
simulation and he's a pretty switched-on
guy in fact it may only be by creating
our own simulations that we are able to
really test our own reality physicist
Silas Beane is one of many theorists who
has said that a simulation must have
limited computing power it can only get
as big as the hardware will allow it so
if we start creating enormous
simulations of our own and those create
over enormous simulations at some point
we'd go
to use up all the processing power
available to whatever hardware our
universe is running on and we're going
to crash it until that happens or we
somehow discover the inner workings of
our reality we can never truly know for
sure if everything we know is just a
simulation thanks for thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42 but in
reality how real is the American
president's power how much power do they
really deserve pretty much every shop
restaurant and bar in the world uses a
system of secret codes